what might be the doubling time of
technological advances in modern society
and how would you measure it I don't
know and I don't know but I'm happy to
try let's look at 30-year runs of the
industrialized world since 1870 with
emphasis on the United States and
compare life at the beginning to life at
the end of each interval how have
exploration and Discovery the drivers of
science shaped our lives from 1870 to
1900 they were great advances in
transportation steam ships crossed the
oceans in record times in 1869 the last
golden spike is hammered completing the
2,000m Transcontinental Railroad across
the United
States this enabled Decades of mobility
and expansion for the
population in 1883 the legendary Orient
Express among many rail routs on the
continent begins its 2,800 km Journey
East from
Paris rail travel rendered
Transportation by stage coach obsolete
along many
routes also in the 1880s German engineer
Carl Benz improves on the internal
combustion engine and birs the first
practical
automobile England inventor John Kemp
Starley perfects the
velocci credit him for the now familiar
safety bicycle which uses two wheels of
equal size and a chain connecting the
rear wheel to the pedals and over that
time powered balloons that enable
Transportation through the air are all
the rage daily life in 1900 would be
unrecognizable to anyone transported
from the year
time to look at published predictions in
1900 for the year
2000 that's what people do when a new
century begins with a clever subtitle
the history of the future the website
paleo future.com specializes in just
that rampant among predictions such as
what appeared in the publications's
punch the Atlantic Monthly and C years
are simple linear extrapolations of what
was happening in
1900 they see the promise of electric
lighting but imagine it only for special
occasions they love Airship travel and
imagine a future where everyone moves
around via their own private balloon
including Santa because who needs magic
reindeer when you have
blimps again humans are linear thinkers
so you can't blame any of them for these
quaint imaginings of their
future the Brooklyn da Eagles last
Sunday newspaper of the 19th century
included a 16-page supplement of
Articles and illustrations titled things
will be so different a hundred years
hence the contributors business and
military leaders pastors politicians and
other experts in their fields ained on
what housework poverty religion
sanitation and War would be like in the
year
2000 they enthused about the potential
potential of electricity and the
automobile and most of the writers
portray a future rich with fanciful
extensions of the day's Technologies
although one futurist could not see the
future at all George h Daniels who
worked for the New York Central and
Hudson River Railroad peered into his
own crystal ball and
predicted it is scarcely possible that
the 20th century will witness
improvements in transportation that will
be as great as were those of the 19th
century written just 3 years before the
invention of flight that's got to be the
most boneheaded prediction ever
made rather than simply underpredict the
future like everybody else he actively
denies a future of Innovations in his
own
field elsewhere in his article Daniels
envisions affordable Global tourism in
the diffusion of white bread to China in
Japan yet he simply can't imagine what
might replace steam as the power source
for ground transportation let alone
heavier than air vehicles flying through
the air even though he stood on the
doorstep of the 20th century this
manager of the world's biggest commuter
rail system could not see beyond the
automobile the locomotive and the
steamship yet another victim of linear
thinking un wittingly embedded in
exponential
growth between 1900 and 1930 the
existence of atoms is confirmed powered
aeroplanes are invented and the range of
flight extends from the 120t 36 M
distance flown in 1903 by the Wright
brothers in the original Wright flyer to
a
5,218 m closed circuit trip in 1930 l by
the Italian aviators major Umberto
madalena and Lieutenant FAO
Chone back on the ground we learned to
exploit radio waves as a fundamental
source of information and
entertainment Urban Transportation
shifts almost entirely from a horsedrawn
economy the backbone of civilization for
thousands of years to an automobile
economy in which you can't give away a
horse this period also sees a World War
in which planes are used in combat for
the first time Orville Wright writing
from Dayton Ohio laments this fact in a
letter dated December 19th 1918 to Alan
R Holly president of the AO Club of
America in New York
City many thanks for your telegram
remembering the 15th anniversary of a
first flight at Kitty Hawk although
Wilbur as well as s would have preferred
to see the Aeroplane developed along
more peaceful lines yet I believe that
its use in this Great War will give
encouragement for its use in other
ways meanwhile cities are electrified to
read at night no longer do you have to
burn wax whale oil or any other source
of flame and over this time Cinema
silent and in black and white becomes a
leading source of entertainment
daily life in 1930 would be
unrecognizable to anyone transported
from the year
1900 from 1930 to 1960 we go from
airplanes flying at speeds of a few
hundred miles per hour to breaking the
sound barrier in
1947 to the dawn of the Space Age
inspired in part by Ballistic Rockets
developed as wartime weapons in 1957 the
Union launches Sputnik Earth's first
artificial satellite traveling at
17,500 mph in low earth orbit in 1958
the world's first commercial jet
airplane the Boeing
707 flown by Pan-American Airways enjoys
a wingspan wider than the distance flown
by the Wright brothers first flight in
1903 this period also sees the invention
of the
laser nuclear weapons from their
invention in 1945 to 1960 a mere 15
years increase in destructive Power by
nearly a factor of
4,000 accompanied by missile
Technologies to deliver their
destructive power anywhere on Earth's
surface within 45
minutes we see the rise of television as
a potent source of instant information
and entertainment as well as the further
rise of Cinema now in color and with
sound daily life in 1960 would be
unrecognizable to anyone transported
from the year
1930 from 1960 to 1990 a cold war
nuclear arms race between the United
States and the Soviet Union threatens
the survival of
civilization though begun in the 1950s
the US stockpile of nuclear warheads
peaks in the 1960s with the Soviets
stockpile peaking in the
1980s the Berlin Wall erected in
1961 becomes the greatest symbol of
Winston Churchill's Iron Curtain
separating Eastern from Western Europe
yet it's dismantled by 1989 as peace
breaks out in Europe the
commercialization of the transistor
allows consumer electronics to miniat
eyes transforming audiovisual equipment
from heavy floor mounted living room
furniture to what you carry in your
pocket the laser goes from a specialized
piece of laboratory equipment costing
tens of thousands of dollars to a
$5.99 laser pointer impulse buy at the
checkout line of Walmart women enter the
workforce in large numbers especially in
professional Fields traditionally held
by men Sunday newspapers Rebrand their
women's section as the home section the
modern gay rights movement catapults to
mainstream attention by the AIDS
epidemic that sweeps the world not until
1987 is homosexuality removed entirely
from the formal list of mental disorders
compiled by the American Psychiatric
association computers go from being
expensive room siiz special purpose
machines used exclusively by the
military and by scientists to desktop
Necessities the personal computer
introduced in the 1980s by IBM and Apple
computer permanently transforms the
daily habits of how people work and play
hospitals in the 1980s see widespread
use of MRIs as a potent tool in the
medical professionals arsenal when
diagnosing the condition of the human
body without first cutting you open in
Back to the Future Part Two
1989 the filmmakers Imagine life in the
distant future of
2015 flying cars are there everybody
wants flying cars in the future but in
one scene Marty McFly the main character
angers his boss during a video call at
home and gets fired from his job this
bad news is Express delivered in that
moment VI a fax not across just one fax
machine his futuristic residence has
three because if everyone owns one fax
machine in
1989 then in the future 26 years later
everyone would surely own three of them
in all fairness to Hollywood it wasn't
just the movies in 1993 AT&T launched an
ad campaign about the future tagline you
will it got most stuff right but
included a TV spot with a person in a
reclined chair on a seashore scribbling
on a tablet about to do something I've
never wanted to do have never needed to
do have never done nor ever will do the
voice over boasts have you ever sent
someone a fax from the beach you will
and the company that'll bring it to you
AT&T oh just one more thing between 19
1960 and 1990 we build the most powerful
rocket ever to launch and with it
Journey nine times to the Moon while
there we orbit land walk skip Golf and
drive three electric buggies across its
Barren Dusty terrain we also develop a
reusable space shuttle and allocate
funds to build an international orbiting
space station the size of a football
field sorry that's three more things
daily life in 1990 would be
unrecognizable to anyone transported
from the year
1960 from 1990 to 2020 we map the human
genome computers become portable small
enough to carry in a backpack the
worldwide web invented in 1989 by
British computer scientist Tim burner's
Lee at the European Organization for
nuclear research CERN in Switzerland
becomes ubiquitous in the
1990s by 2000 searchable websites and
e-commerce are commonplace and everyone
with a computer and access to the
internet obtains an email address early
in this period mobile phones had become
standard for anyone leaving the house
but beginning in 2007 are rapidly
replaced by the pocket-sized smartphone
granting full access to music media and
the internet smart phones further host
countless utilities that enhance
everyday life including a camera that
shoots highquality photos and video oh
and it also makes phone calls the
smartphone may be the single greatest
invention in the history of
inventions in 2020 there are three
billion of them in a world of 8 billion
people before 2007 there were zero show
a smartphone to anyone in 1990 and they
may just resurrect witch burning laws to
eradicate your
magic in 1996 the global positioning
system a navigation tool created
exclusively by the US military for
National Security is formally open to
commercial interests that's when
President Bill Clinton issues a policy
directive declaring GPS to be a dual use
system navigation tools rapidly
commercial ize for everything from
tracking packages to hailing a car
service to selecting a mutually
interested sex partner within four
blocks of your
location in the 2000s social media
platforms changed the communication
landscape of family friends and
especially
politics you can now drive across the
United States in an electric car
charging at any of 40,000 power stations
along the way
all while we Glimpse the dawn of
electric self-driving cars a few more
things once ubiquitous among storefronts
video stores are gone CDs and DVDs come
and go computers are now smart enough to
beat all humans in the board game's
chess and go the TV game show Jeopardy
and damn near everything else that
requires brain power and this sentence
with clear and present meaning in
2020 Google it to see if there's a
smartphone selfie video posted to
YouTube in 4k that went viral is Laden
with mysterious nouns and verbs with no
meaning to anyone in
1990 you know you're living in the
future when you can board a 100 ton
pressurized aluminum tube with wings fly
smoothly in a cushion chair at 500
mph 31,000 ft above Earth's surface and
while crossing the continent get served
a pasta dinner and a mixed drink by
someone whose job in part is to make you
comfortable and for most of the trip you
surf the Internet or watch any one of a
hundred movies only to land safely and
smoothly a few hours later and complain
that the marinara sauce was not to your
liking today swarms with rampant
predictions for what we can expect
mid-century the year
2050 if things continue as they have for
the past 150 years you can guarantee
every one of them will fail maybe that's
good because lately most predictions are
Bleak many foretell a climate change
apocalypse some fear of virus catastroph
with lethality far greater than the 6
million deaths wrought by the co 19
pandemic of
2020 others fear that AI artificial
intelligence will escape its virtual box
and ultimately become our
Overlord on TV and in the movies the
zombie apocalypse feels real a fan once
asked 20th century sci-fi novelist Ray
Bradberry why he imagined Bleak Futures
is civiliz ation doomed he replied no I
write about these Futures so that you
know to avoid them so when someone hints
or declares they have any clue what the
state of the world will be in the year
2050 30 years from 2020 I reflect on our
parade of 30-year windows on human
Affairs there's nothing linear about any
of it the river of discoveries in the
natural world grows exponentially
fed by emergent tributaries of insight
and knowledge guaranteeing to embarrass
any futurist but that won't stop me from
trying with the caveat that when I first
saw the Star Trek TV series in the
1960s I fully embraced a future of warp
drives Photon Torpedoes phasers
Transporters and Aliens but I remembered
thinking no a door can't possibly know
to open for you when you approach it so
time to make a future fool of myself by
the year
2050 neuroscience and our understanding
of the human mind will become so
Advanced that mental illness will be
cured leaving psychologists and
psychiatrists without jobs in a shift
that Echoes the rapid conversion from
horses to automobiles in the early 20th
century self-driving electric vehicles
will fully place all cars and trucks on
the road if you want to be nostalgic
with your fancy combustion engine sports
car you can drive on specially designed
car tracks akin to horse riding stables
of
today the human space program will fully
transition to a space industry supported
not by tax dollars but by tourism and
anything else people dream of doing in
space we develop a perfect antiviral
serum and cure cancer medicines will
tailor to your DNA leaving no adverse
side effects we will resist the urge to
merge the circuitry of computers with
the circuitry of our brains we will
learn to regrow lost limbs and failing
organs bringing us up to the level of
other regenerating animals on earth like
salamanders starfish and
Lobsters instead of becoming our
Overlord and ens slaving us all
artificial intelligence will be just
another helpful feature of the tech
infrastructures that serve our daily
lives yes we live in special times only
because it's all
special what's driving it all when we
think of civilization we commonly
reflect on how engineering and
technology has shaped our lives dig a
little deeper and find ongoing
scientific discovery that enables and
empowers this
progress 19th century advances in
thermodynamics gave Engineers the
necessary understanding of energy and
heat to design and perfect their
engines around the same time discoveries
in electromagnetism informed all
thoughts about how to create and
distribute electrical
power Einstein's theory of relativity
published in 1905 and 1915 with
ultimately provide the Precision that
GPS satellite timing requires among
countless other extraordinary
Revelations about our universe from how
the Sun makes energy to the Big Bang
itself quantum mechanics in the 1920s
became the landscape on which all modern
Electronics would be based especially
the creation storage and retrieval of
digital
information Material Science and ongoing
Enterprise that explores new Alloys
composits and the texture of surfaces
has transformed everything we see touch
wear and use in our industrialized
World each of these areas represents
entire branches of the physical sciences
with discoveries reported by scientists
in research papers that once appeared in
journals on shelves but now display on
the internet you didn't have in
1990 yes we live in special times only
because it's all special which brings to
mind this
[Music]
offsitedatasync only conceive this
sentence in a pre-scientific
era before exponentials had even been
imagined and before anybody emerged from
the Dark of the cave to
explore today it's all new Under the Sun
and Moon and Stars the only thing about
it that doesn't change is the
exponential rate of change
itself
[Music]